mme olive et aujourd'hui je dois
commencer en vous remerciant par ça la
recette de la veille avait soudain
prométhée mais depuis un temps depuis un
temps fou eh bien ça va des vosges a vu
le bouille à z il voyagea des rascasses
que voilà ça des grondins cdu saint
pierre il ya du congo il y avait vive
faire bien attention à la piqûre de
ville ou quoi en dire ça il y a des
côtes cassées
on peut mettre les crustacés plomb
naturellement on pourrait mettre
davantage de poissons
c'est à dire davantage de sortes de
poissons mais aujourd'hui je les
trouvais en quelque sorte que ça eh bien
nous allons réparer ce poisson c'est à
dire lors le séparer non séparés ce qui
va nous servir à faire la bouillabaisse
elle même est ce qui va nous servir à
préparer la bouillabaisse
alors voyons ici les nuances que vous
allez comprendre
pour vous je coupe un jeu bien attendez
je vais même faire autre chose je refais
voyez je pars vous partez là je partais
trop vide
en définitive je vais revenir ici et je
m'en vais commencer par le commencement
c'est un désert fermer ses volets mieux
vous avez raison un peu d'huile dans une
80's une cocotte
jusque là rien de très sain dans cette
huile on va mettre des oignons
enfin un oignon 1 oignon et 2006 ici là
on est venu parce que je fais en sarre
la wiimote y avait l'idée c'était c'est
vrai que les gros noms harry caine sous
les membres alain delagnes en rentrant
dans 10 des fenouils qui fait nous y
tient un bouquet garni et je vais te
tutoyer le fenouil
oui et non yoyo pourquoi oui en quelque
sorte si on n'avait pas d'amis mais si
on a de l'année on peut se passer de
nous enfin le fun with the game la nuit
à la sur le fond de l'équipe que nous
avons de la delahaye voyez vous pas mal
de lengronne panale et nous allons
l'écraser s'il n'a pas grande importance
quand les condors passe
lancée en fond et se comble passerons
nous sommes en donne sur le fond qui va
nous servir à faire l'habillage est
autrement dit je vous ai fait tout à
l'heure une restriction je vous ai dit
nous allons faire pendre le poisson qui
lui servira à faire la baisse est celui
qui ont servi à faire le point bon tout
ça ensemble et nous allons mélangé de
faire dorer les oignons
est ce que nous y avait se prépare
réellement d'une demi heure oui oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est vrai on
arrivera dans la sphère en devient un
agent nous la manche ne sera fatale sera
absolument n'agit pas vite août afin
s'est dit quand tout à fait c'est lui
l'homme est un tout petit peu plus et
puis je m'en vais reprendre ce que
j'avais commencé cette année lui la
préparation des passants alors d'une
part la tête c'était lequel est là que
cette place saint pierre rivère de
morceaux comme ceci je continue avec
l'avim
parce que la facture de 18 très
dangereuse réellement dangereux alors là
on enlever les picards ont remarqué la
vive ce qui est vraiment ce qui est tout
de même qu'il devient beaucoup moins
dangereux alors ça ce sont les rascasses
ne sait pas faire de bouillabaisse la
rascasse
je n'ai pas si grave et de cigales
d'ailleurs car ça s'appelle aussi les
cigales de mer vous a fait des cigalons
parce que je suppose que vous avez
préféré le petit
dire ça comme ça jean michel lemaire oui
par ma famille rigolade
c'est pour ça
alors tous les bons morceaux des gares
tandis que le clan la martinique le
voyait tellement petit il ne
m'intéressait pas rascasse toujours
pareil
mais alors à l'envers et voici le comble
c'est énorme
lui et tout couper alors tout en quatre
morceaux
même séparés vous avez géré et j'y
travaille
oui là on va lentement chez toi alors là
je vais séparer les queues de
langoustines des têtes savoir ce que je
vais faire c'est également très
important on en regardant bien
bon ok c'est combien tout ça c'est à peu
près ce que fait le voyage des sports
aussi personnes environ quatre personnes
deux très très bon appétit super sont
normales cet oubli ou chacune de ses
langoustines qui sont crus les d'écraser
légèrement comme ceux ci le corps le
corps auquel donne bien tous leurs
toutes celles d'un tour
ce sont les premières que je vais mettre
dans le fond parce que l'abandonner
henry selon elle va donner du goût aux
fonds de bouillabaisse que je vais
préparer très importe comment j'aurais
tout de suite maintenant boosting à
isoler ce que je ne ferai pas pour le
reste du poisson
vous avez dû certainement en criant je
suis de se laisser piquer à la ville
dans tout ça revient voilà avec vous les
gars du pousseur revient avec le bouquet
garni et maintenant nous pouvons me dire
que ses revenus alors dû ajouter le
poisson pas le poisson
voilà est immédiatement je vais arroser
nous donne peu de vin blanc peut être un
peu merci free pourquoi ça couvre ou non
nous n'aurons pas question et un verre
de vin blanc
en plus on en est pas du tout d'ailleurs
que ce serait pas grave
des lots par contre est par contre
devant la lola l'eau elle vient
effleurer
bref le répare tout juste un verre ça va
me jeter faire d'autre ça va me sauter
faire mon come bouillabaisse
je vais même le salaire est gérant très
légèrement on le voit là le poivre et
non moins légèrement poivre de cayenne
où je vais ajouter passe comme si je
vais ajouter les tomates
ici je mangeais très peu voyez vous y
viendrez comme là et je vais mettre les
tomates alors les tomates
je vous donne un petit couteau si vous
voulez bien le donnez vous avoir enlevé
le côté vert de la tomate et aux soins
gentil ce merci catherine je vais mettre
des tomates fraîches que l'on met 4 ou 5
vous enlevez simplement
oh je vais m comme je suis un petit
morceau we tomates nous dotons fur et à
mesure jusque là j'aime bien compliqué
tout le monde sait qu'ils ont une ouïe
abaissement non je crois qu'on fait des
ersatz de bouillabaisse voit la vraie la
fin vous savez là je pourrais ouvrir une
parenthèse tout le moins de fois tout le
monde de quoi corser pour j'ai très peur
de la critique au contraire on va me
dire mais vous savez nous la raison de
très bonnes phases de tension extrême et
je sais que je trouvais jeu devant de
calais les goûters de villaret ça veut
dire qu'il ya peut-être même plusieurs
façons mais bien sûr là je vais mettre
un tout petit peu d'eau thomas
concentrer tout de même pas ce que je
vais gagner un peu de temps parce que
vous voulez qu'elle soit réellement
dalles de tv que nos spectateurs ne vous
trompe pas oui mais je sais que mes
techniciens la bouton et mon dieu je
tiens beaucoup à leur père après
chercher eux mêmes qu'ils oui je ne veux
pas que vous avez dit un jeu lâche sous
prétexte que je fais en russie vous avez
dit un jour si elle était mauvaise ça se
saura que ça s'arrête c'est vrai c'est
d'ailleurs très près alors voyez j'ai
tout mis ici d'un atout mais vous allez
voir le reste leur lettre à part alors
voulez vous allez le couvert que je vous
prie 4 et merci beaucoup
et maintenant nous passons à la chose la
plus importante de tous c'est la
marinade
s'il faut marine et la bouillabaisse
alors ça c'est pas vous dire mais c'est
là je crois le secret n'a vous aves le
secret de la vie la baisse réside à la
façon dont lé mari prenons un plat et
nous allons mettre dans ce plat les
morceaux qui vont nous servir à composer
la bouillabaisse le contre le saint
pierre les vivent les rascasses et des
langoustines et que maintenant nous
n'arrêterons pas la routine ça ne
servirait à rien parce qu'elle honda
dans une carapace et pas pousser quand
elles ne sont pas accessibles à cette
préparation que nous faisons maintenant
qui est la marina
qu'allez vous mettre des biens dans
cette marinade je le mets d'abord le
safran le chargement pour vélo alors là
je vais soupoudré saupoudré de safran
légèrement il s'agit de sa forme de
fleur de safran en poudre rien vous
là je suppose de sortie tout même femme
a pas tellement non non ne croyez pas et
puis je m'en vais mettre les feuilles de
temps ça c'est très très important
les feuilles de thym et une feuille de
laurier
je vais également briser sa série midi
voyez vous je vais briser ma feuille de
teint très finement également dessus ce
n'est pas tout je vais mettre un peu
dany dan liqueur les liqueurs annie
apéritif ça y est vous comme ça très peu
là et puis je vais mettre le pauvre et
paient maintenant le poivre de cayenne
également très très peu de poivre de
cayenne
sans revenir en mémoire la famille
touché 1 et puis je vais mettre de
l'huile de l'huile d'olive ou de
l'alloeu le moins fruits qui est
possible ou alors si je n'ai pas d'huile
d'olive le mettre un peu d'huile de très
bonne qualité et ça c'est là le secret
d'un village est bon et les destinations
muni de sa flotte alors ça ce n'est pas
grave car ceci je vais le mariner comme
ceux ci en ayant soin de bien faire
absorber et où le bien le remuer il veut
laisser pendant environ une heure ou
deux voyez-vous n'a pas plu non mais en
l'occurrence cela il suffira nous ont
fait voir comment il fallait faire aider
toutefois ceux qu'il faut donc laisser
sable deux heures il faut s'y prendre
là alors ça nous allons maintenant cette
bouillabaisse qui est à mariner nous
pourrons mettre dessus les queues de
langoustines puis on n'a pas
l'importance du golfe désert derrière de
bord troisième opération car il ya trois
opérations essentielles la troisième
opération ce sont les poids ça c'est
très gentil merci
ces sites ont été ménagés merci 4 et la
halle à l'époque
normalement à cette époque de l'année
les poireaux sont très beaux sont gros
et on fait ce qu'on appelle une julienne
de poireaux je vous ai déjà vous fait
voir comment vu julien leparoux
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas trouvé le groupe
parrot j'ai trouvé que deux semaines
partie minuscule minuscule laissant
quelque sorte
et ce sont donc avec des poireaux comme
ça que j'aurais à préparer cette
bouillabaisse
néanmoins je prends que ce ne doit pas
nous ennuyer nous réussirons
vous prendre au lieu de les couper dans
le sens de la longueur alors les coupes
est essentielle à la fin et c'est contre
6 respectivement
car il faut les faire fondre dans
l'autre je les reprends les jours
comment nous en livre et on les coupe
dans le quotidien dans un seul sens ça
va suffire étrangers qui sont déjà alors
on ne coupe que jusqu'au vert est
cependant mais pas trop de verre et
surtout le blanc du poireau oui au
projet de cette importance là nous
allons nous arrêter ici ce soir suffise
là et ça nous allons le faire tomber
avec beurre et huile là le beurre et en
facultatif la gérer insiste comme simple
que ça va un peu fort non non non non
ils font ça très fort je l'avais ouvrir
notre gaz pour me permettre justement
très dégagé la tête tranquille ici
voyez-vous le procès alors dans une
petite casserole
vous allez mettre du beurre c'est
catherine voilà et puis pendant que
ceux-ci varient soler la cuire nous
allons passer le fond qui est déjà plus
car il est déjà chez web et dans le
passé deux fois une fois pour nous
débarrasser des arts est une seconde
fois pour le passé vraiment c'est à dire
se passe est très sérieux alors voici
non le première fois ce n'est pas très
sérieux tout ça
un chinois non la première fois dans le
passé comme la loi qui barre sa une
exemple voila voila je m'en vais
l'appeler tout petit peu faisceau on va
bien du côté boireau
c'est bien ça en passant la voilà
l'espoir aux ambiances acquitté merci
car j'ai alors celle-ci mais voilà ça
s'est fini c'est terminé je reprends ici
les poissons marinés
il y à 3 heures 2 heures de sa alors ici
voyez vous nous avons puis au beurre et
huile mais surtout à lui les poireaux
qui sont maintenant il a aussi
pratiquement cuit sans fouille ils ont
fondu de 100 pays alors ça c'est terminé
nous avons plus besoin et bien retirons
remuer encore une fois notre marina bay
sa liste pour les deux airs alors
renversé les poireaux au fond de la
cocotte
nous allons les déplacer
si l'accord est dans laquelle je sais
avec un peu nos par exemple et ça
pourrait être avec toi c'est comme un
blanc aujourd'hui vous êtes tous âges
voilà c'est avec un peu d'eau là dessus
je vais je vais mettre tous les poissons
il était à glisser comme ceci et je
revoterai chinois avec la marinade bien
entendu avec toute la marinade faut le
dire de façon c'est gentil ça alors je
vais d'abord des glaces et c'est en
quelque sorte le plat de la marina de
fonda marina pas comme ceux ci et je
vais mettre le restant comme ceux ci sur
le poisson d'un lac
or la compote
et ça vous allez le faire rejoindre le
reste votre déglaçage le rejoindre la
révolte le reste on peut rire
voilà je crois que c'est fini il n'y a
plus rien vous avez utilisé tous ceux
qui étaient sur la table dont on ne sait
s'il y avait beaucoup de choses et voilà
qu'il incarne ici
maintenant nous n'avons plus qu'à
laisser cuire quelques minutes quelques
minutes seulement et a découvert
nous allons cependant faire une chose
vous menez une assiette je vous prie
donc ya quelque chose que l'on a
l'habitude de faire d'habitude nous ne
faisons pas l'habitude mais nous allons
faire je vais justement goûter pour
savoir si alors voyez vous on refroidit
dans une assiette comme se dit pourquoi
ne pas bouger
si vous voulez bien goûter vous allez me
dire si pas manquer si c'est assez salée
pas tout ça c'est sûr et c'est ce que je
pensais eh bien nous allons resserrer un
disque dur c'est pas assez à ces années
par ailleurs non denses et une question
simple où je savais que je savais qu'ils
étaient une question c'est est ce que
c'est qu'un homme alors je serai à
nouveau et j'ai dix minutes environ
depuis son jeu suffisamment d'abord et
bien maintenant voyez vous nous allons
faire nous allons réparer le père le
pain pour la bouillabaisse juin ne
savait et nous a joué un très grand rôle
en pourrait aussi faire cuire cette
bouillabaisse avec des pommes de terre
on pourrait cuir avec des pommes de
terre que nous mettrions dans le fond de
la casserole
alors ça c'est une méthode c'était la
méthode d'ailleurs saint tropez ou dans
les hauts de saint tropez on met
toujours du des pommes de terre dans la
bouillabaisse puis il ya d'autres
régions aussi où on n'en met pas autre
chose qu'on met dans la bouillabaisse et
que j'allais oublier de m c'est un peu
de zeste de citron et bien je vais le
mettre tout de suite car il n'est pas
trop tard il n'est pas trop tard pour le
maître je vais mettre deux principaux
d'ébriété le moment dans la marina comme
j'ai mis tous les ingrédients dans la
marinade j'aurais dû également non vous
avez mis le safran le sait ça y est
c'est bien ce n'est pas trop tard
j'ai pensé à cette eau mois n'oubliez
pas les éditions alors ici on peut aussi
mettre du zeste d'orange
n'est ce pas un général en provence on
met souvent du zeste d'orange on fait
sécher les élèves est dangereux sur
et puis tout l'hiver et puis alors après
on veut on s'en sert on l'aimé comme ça
alors ici je coupe du pain se perd on
peut le faire griller par exemple on
peut le mettre tel que ou bien on peut
aussi le faire rissoler à lui ya
beaucoup de méthode
aujourd'hui nous allons le faire griller
de glee tout de même que tels que
général guéï et est passé à l'ail voilà
voilà voilà à peu près la méthode la
rigole il dit précisant même si
catherine le bon et bien sûr une plaque
3,6 alors le ranger pour le faire
griller référer au four tout simplement
oui je veux faire le yo yo pendant ce
temps là la bouillabaisse pour
accueillir et soit suffisamment cuite
lorsque j'aurai fini alors je vous ai
dit qu'il y avait des recettes de
bouillabaisse autant qu'il y avait de
petits pays de calandre que même on peut
dire sur la méditerranée on prétend que
le mot de bouillabaisse vient de ce que
on le fait bouillir en se baissant la
bouille que l'on fait un se baissa alors
les bordelais qui sont très prétentieux
comme tout le monde le sait prétendre
que c'est en ont mais baissent car vous
savez que perth et en inquiéter bordeaux
oui d'ailleurs parmi baisse a été
pendant quelques temps secrétaire
général de la comédie française
alors il prétendait que c'était une de
ses aïeux qui s'appelait baisse qui
avait trouvé la bouille de baisse la
bouillabaisse j'ai dit ça c'est parce
qu'ils voulaient en faire mon label un
temps que la télévision ne sera pas à
bordeaux nous n'aurons pas cette version
non non non nous laisserons méridionaux
toulet tout le bénéfice de la caisse de
la la fraternité de la bourse alors la
pure allemand de bouillabaisse on trouve
partout les tout le monde prétend que
c'est la sienne qui est la meilleure
mais je pense moi non moi je fasse que
la meilleure bouillabaisse
c'est évidemment celle qu'on fait au
bord de la mer au loin de réussir à nez
avec du poisson qu'on vient de ramasser
et les pêcheurs qui font du loup et
reste très simple une qui ne prennent
pas ou là
eux qui ne prennent pas ils ne prennent
pas tous ces poissons restent ils ont
beaucoup beaucoup de variétés poissons
les mesures tout ça ce gros gros
avantage et cette supériorité d'être du
poisson qui sort de deux lots et je
crois que ça ça ne se passera rien ne
remplace pas prévient voilà nous allons
avoir ici en quelques secondes deux
secondes vraiment raconter jusqu'à 3 et
je crois qu'il sera grille
oui ça suffit c'est fou alors nous
allons faire deux choses d'abord nous
allons préparer le potage qui va se
servir ici de dire non non je ne ne
touchez pas
touchez pas alors nous allons à y est
légèrement pendant que la bouillabaisse
continue puis ça il faut qu'elle
continue de la rai est ce qu'en pense
pas que ceci oui je suis modeste où
normalement on aille plus que cela pas
pour qui aime l'ail et je crois que vous
vous êtes très amateur de poèmes mais
pas tellement bas aussi j'adore j'adore
ce très bon d'ailleurs ça donne des
nuits calmes ça fait bien envie vous
mais pas en danger de mort il faut pas
qu'un jour en basset l'aïoli si vous
voulez déjà dit je vous l'avais
dirigeant s être fait d'urgence des
choses je m'exécute
j'adore l'aïoli jetons triolet qui ce
merveilleux calculer le nombre de
recettes que vous avez déjà dernier rama
voulzy jamais de l'aiguillé vers un nom
il avait promise j'ai tellement peur de
me faire ça côté asticoter parlée par
les méridionaux qui vont venir mais de
oliveira
vraiment très souvent bien que ce soit
très gentille si vous le sentez moi j'ai
vu et tout ça bouillonne est vraiment en
une demi-heure compte tenu bien entendu
des deux heures de marina on peut faire
une bouillabaisse ce qui étonnait
merveilleux et puis il faut aussi aller
pêcher le poisson si c'est pendant les
vacances
nos amis font ça voilà ça prend un
double une lumière dans ce cas là le
plus difficile de la place pour dire que
j'ai c'est la seule chose que j'aurais
été capable de faire bon et bien voilà
ça y est nous allons maintenant passer
aux choses très sérieuses c'est à dire
et sage
c'est à dire il va se présenter ça va se
présenter en deux parties et soit l'une
dans la csa alors je voudrais vous
demander de vous donner une écumoire
voilà j'espère qu'elle suffira
voilà alors je pourrais également plat
je les vois tout ça ça arrive
admirablement résisté fait exprès oui
mais vraiment tant dévoué pas le poisson
sous les mains sont avant tout là comme
ça et enfin leur jeu est rappelé au fur
et à mesure que vous sortez rappelé que
vous avez alors j'ai mis des poissons
avec comme base la rascasse la rascasse
le grondin rouge
rémy du congre j'ai mis du saint pierre
et des sites naturels manger tout ce que
j'aimais rue être bien d'autrui
donc surtout lorsque l'on fait des
élections nous ya baisse et que l'on
veut prendre à voir la précaution de
faire le potage sagna peut parer sa
bouillabaisse avec des petits poissons
de roche bon mais la girelle le
comment s'appellent ces poissons que
l'on maîtrisait tout ça en fait en fait
d'excellents otage au départ qui
s'accommode fort bien ensuite de la
préparation dit que william bell c'est à
dire avec laquelle on finit le jeu pêche
je suis au bout de ma pêche oui et vous
alors là on retrouve tout ce qu'on a mis
le débat - quelques petites choses qui
ont fourni par exemple vous donnons aux
poireaux totalement faux là je m'en vais
avec le feu ces prêts non seulement je
suis dans voyez-vous dans la nuit de
huit ans que nous étions rivaux et y ont
abordé des minutes mais néanmoins néant
motorola ailleurs lorsque je reste
l'ébullition ça reste voici que je vais
extraire immédiatement je vais verser
otage dans la marmite ici et après ça et
les jeunes ça prend quelques années il à
présent vous voulez pas en servir vous
montrer comment on procède avec la voilà
et si vous voulez alors que d'en
asservir une paire de lacets plateau
s'il reste une minute pour financier
place et la gentillesse de me donner le
look également les dessous de vous alors
là on choisit un morceau de chaque
poisson c'est un mensonge on compte un
morceau de raska ça c'est du
l'occurrence ce n'est pas dans ce cas
c'est du du gondor du chercheur et puis
un ou deux morceaux décrit là quelques
morceaux de pain que je vais arroser le
tout en ayant soin de bien
humecter le teint comme ceux ci il nous
restera à vous dire
bon appétit
[Musique]